direction la grange de meslay pour son
58e festival jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine 8 pianiste soliste vont se
succéder sur place pour le plus grand
bonheur des amateurs de musique
classique
en parallèle des confères de master
classes avaient lieu ce jeudi à
destination des élèves du conservatoire
de tours pour les encadrer la célèbre
pianiste claire désert un moment de
pédagogie et de transmission également
ouvert au public est suivi par notre
journaliste aurélie renault
le mouvement lent de la sonate de chopin
pour violoncelle et piano est interprété
par alexandra et millau ils sont
aujourd'hui dirigée par claire désert
professeurs du conservatoire national de
paris
la soliste accompagne régulièrement lors
qu'istres de radio france le
philharmonique de paris ou de québec
aujourd'hui elle transmet son talent aux
jeunes musiciens tourangeau c'est vrai
que la master class est toujours un
espace différent par rapport aux cours
qu'ils peuvent avoir au conservatoire
avec leurs professeurs réguliers chaque
semaine j'ai envie qui flashe sur cette
journée qu'ils étaient très heureux
d'entendre de la musique de voir aussi
qu'on pouvait être heureux en faisant de
la musique
peu un rêve que tu veux pas laisser
partir la claire désert ponctuent la
partition d'imaginaire elle travaille
avec les sensations de ces jeunes élèves
un dow reste bien le dos mais après la
master class la manière de jouer a
changé s'il est très bonne chose qui
nous a dit sur les détails c'est
vraiment très intéressant ça nous a aidé
à bien nous écouter
bah mieux jouer notre morceau en fait
moi c'est pas cours normal parce que
c'est comme un grand musicien c'est pas
juste un prof qui te dit c'est pas
annoncés par les c'est plus que c'est
plus quatre à cinq ans
on pense des images bien là ça varie
beaucoup plus et puis ça nous aide
beaucoup plus d'aisance
que ces choses est vrai qu'on a toujours
nous dans l'est dans les conservatoires
toujours cette appréhension du contact
avec l'artiste qui est habitué de jouer
avec les plus de travailler avec les
plus grands et de se mettre avec un
élève qui a acquis en cyclo un gank un
deux trois ou quatre ou cinq ans piano
c'est pas évident et clair le fait
magnifiquement bien une master class qui
s'achèvera par un concert donné par les
élèves puissent et la pédagogue qui sera
sur scène pour un grand moment de
musique de chambre
[Musique]